what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some pretty big news
coming from the president of Marvel
Studios himself Kevin feige he was
recently interviewed by Entertainment
Weekly and he talked about a lot he
talked about very important upcoming
Phase 5 and 6 details he also talks
about the future of Marvel Studios in
general and then he talks a little bit
about mutants and the X-Men and the MCU
but when speaking about the future of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe perhaps
one of the most important things that we
have learned from this article is that
Marvel Studios is going to be changing
things with Disney plus now the Disney
Plus shows so far have kind of been hit
or miss for people some people love some
shows while other people hate them then
you have the people who love every show
that comes out from Marvel Studios and
then you have people who are not
watching the shows anymore because they
haven't really enjoyed them and they are
a lot to keep up with Marvel Studios
went from releasing two to three movies
a year to releasing three to four movies
a year but also at the same time
releasing four to five to six to Plus
shows a year that is a lot more content
than they're used to producing but it
looks like that is about to change so
before we dive into what he said on the
mutants and the future of the MCU let's
specifically talk about what he said in
regards to the quantity of Disney Plus
shows that they're going to be putting
out so Entertainment Weekly asked Kevin
feige if he saw the recent Saturday
Night Live skit this skit basically kind
of poked fun at how many shows are being
released so frequently and a bunch of
different shows are coming from a bunch
of different streaming platforms Kevin
feige said yes but then he elaborated
and in his response we got some really
important details about Marvel Studios
he said yes he saw it then he said I do
think one of the powerful aspects of
being at Marvel Studios is having these
films and shows hit the Zeitgeist it is
harder to hit the Zeitgeist when there's
so much product out there and so much
content as they say which which is a
word that I hate and they know that he
laughs as he said that he continues to
say but we want Marvel Studios and the
MCU projects to really stand out and
stand above so people will see that as
we get further into phase five and six
the pace at which we're putting out the
Disney Plus shows will change so they
can each get a chance to shine so Kevin
feige confirms the pace at which Disney
plus is putting out shows is going to
change but I know everybody's asking
well what exactly does that mean well
Entertainment Weekly had that exact same
thought and thankfully they asked him
that question for us after Kevin feige
talked about the pace changing
Entertainment Weekly asked so when you
say the pace will change do you mean
spacing them out or putting out fewer
shows a year and Kevin feige said both I
think so his literal response was quote
both I think end quote basically
confirming what we expected was going to
happen a lot of fans have been
complaining that there are just too many
Disney Plus shows out there right now
coming from Marvel Studios and coming
from studios in general right now and
unfortunately a lot of people have been
complaining that the quality of the
shows not just with the CGI that people
love to complain about but also with the
writing hasn't really been up to par
well it looks like Marvel Studios has
heard those complaints have evaluated
their shows have evaluated their
strategies and are now changing things
plus not to mention Bob chapek is now
gone and Bob Iger is back and rumor had
it that Bob chapek was all about
quantity but now that Bob Iger is back
it's about quality so Kevin feige and
Marvel Studios probably doesn't have to
actually release as much as they did
before which is a great thing because
now they can get back to focusing on
quality and Kevin feige just confirmed
right here that is what they're going to
do they're going to release fewer Disney
Plus shows a year and have them more
spaced out which should result in them
being better so this is fantastic news
and I can't wait to see how Marvel
Studios changes for the better in the
future and Kevin feige does talk about
how we can expand expect these changes
in Phase five and six so we could be
getting a reshuffling of our slates I
don't think any big movies will be
pushed back but some shows might and in
this interview Kevin feige even talks
about how some things are setting up
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars but some
shows and movies aren't they are kind of
just Standalone so if we are going to be
getting any delays or cancellations it's
probably going to be with those shows or
movies that don't really connect to the
King Dynasty or Secret Wars that much
now of course like I mentioned we have
to talk about the mutants because Kevin
feige talked about the mutants and the
X-Men Entertainment Weekly asked Kevin
feige I'm curious one of the big
introductions in phase four was mutants
nemour and Kamala Khan are both
explicitly referred to as mutants what
can you tell us about how mutants and
the X-Men may or may not play into the
future and they note that Kevin feige
laughs while he says this but he says
you know I think we've said the word
once he says Kamala talks about a
genetic mutation and the more refers to
himself as a mutant amongst his own
people and mutant is a real genetic term
not just a comic book term but part of
the fun is that I've been at this
company for half my life and we're just
now tapping into arguably one of the
biggest aspects of the publishing
history it's pretty remarkable and it's
a testament to the house of ideas and
what Marvel publishing has done these 80
years the question is how to do it and
when to do it and that's something we've
been working on for years now we know
but we're not going to talk about it and
he said that as he left however
Entertainment Weekly did pry just a
little bit more asking about the X-Men
they said that's fair but I'm curious
what it's like for you to be thinking
about mutants again especially because
you started your superhero career
producing the X-Men movies then Kevin
feige said it's amazing and we've got
Hugh Jackman coming back for our first
Dead Deadpool film within the MCU that's
our first R rated film so he confirms
it's R-rated so whatever rumors have
been going out that says Deadpool might
not be rated R we can put them to rest
now as the president himself has
confirmed Deadpool will indeed be rated
R he continues to say to have Hugh come
back is incredible for me personally
that is where I started I remember
sitting behind the camera well behind
the camera at his audition for the film
it was his first onset audition and he
flew up to Toronto to do a read with
Anna Paquin for him and for me and I
think for all of the fans of Marvel it's
unbelievable what has happened in those
23 years it's very full circle having
him come back in this new Deadpool film
so Kevin feige remains to be a safe that
is sealed shut not giving anything away
about any of the secrets that Marvel
Studios has in store however he did
confirm they have their plan for the
X-Men ready so they know the how and
they know the win from what he confirmed
and it kind of sounds like we really
aren't going to be getting a true
introduction to the X-Men the new X-Men
I should say until phase seven after the
Multiverse Saga after the King Dynasty
and after Secret Wars now we do know
that older X-Men will be returning and
they will be in secret Wars they're
basically going to come back like Hugh
Jackman is coming back for Deadpool 3.
the Multiverse is real and is in full
motion now we're going to see other
characters from other universes come to
our universe plus not to mention Our
Heroes will most likely travel to other
universes as well where we will run into
other X-Men older X-Men and probably new
variants that we haven't seen before but
most importantly it's been said that
Kevin feige is going to see this as sort
of his farewell to the older X-Men the
original X-Men because like the article
said that's where his career began
starting on the very first X-Men film so
Kevin feige will finally get to bring
them into what he has created the MCU
and then he will get a proper goodbye
and then we'll say hello to the new
X-Men in phase seven so big changes
coming from Marvel they are changing up
the frequency that they released Disney
Plus shows hopefully improving the
quality of the Disney Plus shows and
movies and of course the X-Men are
coming soon so lots of insanely exciting
stuff so be sure to let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest MCU news for live updates
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof